Most people know or remember from school that
underneath it all reality is not based on
billiard balls and things that match our experience
in the physical world, but on a system called
quantum mechanics.
And the rules of quantum mechanics are rather
strange and not very intuitive to us and so
they don't act like the higher level rules
that we've built computers on so far.
So there's a bunch of research to study whether
or not you can do things in quantum mechanics
that perform computation in ways that we can't
do at the level of mechanical systems or electronic
systems that we use.
In particular it seems possible in theory
to do very, very huge amounts of computing
in quantum mechanics, sort of as some people
would imagine it as though you were tapping
into millions and trillions and billions of
parallel universes and having computations
take place in all those parallel universes
until an answer is found in one and is revealed
to you in your universe.
Well, that's a little bit mystical.
I don't know if anyone can give you the true
answer on that, but there are people who believe
that they can make a computer that uses these
properties of quantum computing to solve some
very, very specific problems much, much faster
than the way we solve them today with computers.
And when I say much, much faster, so much
faster that if you were to turn the entire
universe into an ordinary computer like the
one on your desk, it still could not outcompete
the quantum computer at solving these problems.
Now, one of the problems that can be solved
this way, in theory, yet no one has built
this computer that we know of, but one of
the problems that can be solved is a math
problem that we believe to be hard, which
is to say factoring really large numbers.
And because we believe that problem to be
really hard, we have used that as the lock
in all of the computer security that we use
in the world today, almost all of it.
And if that lock can be broken, because the
quantum computer makes easy what everyone
else believe to be incredibly hard, the person
with the quantum computer could break most
of the cryptography, all the traffic you see
going across the web, a lot of the financial
transaction traffic, a lot of the authentication,
all of that stuff becomes vulnerable to a
computer that's done that.
Now, Edward Snowden has told us that the NSA
does indeed have a research project to build
this, and I actually feel good about that
because Snowden didn't tell us they already
had one.
Now, the way you will know that someone has
a quantum computer like this if it's made
public, is you look out your window on Wall
Street and if you see bankers and stock people
running screaming in terror waving their arms
you know that someone has developed a quantum
computer.
There are a few other things that could cause
that.
By the way many people are skeptical that
it ever will happen.
There's some people who think something will
always stand in the way of this being true.
But other people are very serious about it.
Now, there's a second type of device, which
is also being called a quantum computer made
by a company up in Vancouver called D-Wave.
The D-Wave Computer solves other specialty
problems and not the one that affects cryptography.
It's, for example, good at solving a fairly
hard problem.
Imagine you're out in a mountain range and
you're in a valley somewhere in a mountain
range and you're asked what's the lowest of
valley in this mountain range?
Now, if you had to solve that yourself you'd
have to like climb to the top of all the mountains
and look down because in your valley it's
easy to find the bottom of your valley, but
you don't know if there's another valley over
next to you that's lower or not.
And their quantum computer they claim is able
to do things like solve that instantly, find
that bottom of the valley.
Why is that useful?
Because that's a problem that we call optimization,
having a really complex system and trying
to find the most efficient, the lowest energy,
the lowest cost way to deal with it.
And so that type of quantum computer could
help us a lot at solving big business problems,
big data problems.
That's actually very interesting too and they've
actually sold a couple of these computers
to have people who want to experiment on making
that happen.
So two different things people call quantum
computers.
Both capable of solving some very specific
problems, which could have big consequences
for our society, but not for example something
that makes your spreadsheet go a lot faster.